now this is gonna shock you to think
this is happening under the watch of one
of the best presidents on immigration
which is President Trump but according
to judicial watch the federal government
has been quietly relocating illegal
immigrants around the country on
commercial flights the president of the
National Border Patrol Council Brandon
Judd said that's because Obama is
administration holdovers are still
running major agencies he joins us now
via Skype from Alta Montana also joining
us from San Diego is immigration
advocate Enrique morones from San Diego
as I said gentlemen it's great to see
both of you Brandon let's start with you
now this is a program which took place
and began under President Obama and it
was originally passed I think in 2008
and it eventually was like child
trafficking concerns motivated the idea
that you can't immediately deport minors
back to non contiguous countries that's
different however from relocating them
across the country on commercial flights
correct it is and it actually expanded
from 2008 to releasing anybody that it
claimed a credible fear that said that
they didn't want to go back to their
country and we were releasing all
individuals that they crossed the border
illegally enrique why is this the way to
enforce american immigration law on the
books in other words to me it seems like
a magnet if you tell people if you get
across the border we will protect you we
will send you to a sponsor as enrique
there I just see a truck otherwise
Enriquez changed and we'll just send you
all over the country to various
locations and you'll be able to stay
there yes so what of that Enrique well
first of all of course it's not true
that's not what its taking place in the
last six years there's been less
migrants crossing the border especially
from Mexico now it's mostly Central
Americans and it's very very difficult
to get asylum very difficult most don't
get inside them so it's not a matter of
just saying I want to say I'm and you
get in like the Border Patrol Union
likes to state if that were happening
then the Border Patrol Union is
responsible because been promoting that
concept to smugglers yeah he start
President Bush there is a program yeah
the people that do have credible fear
that do have a family member
many of them are allowed to go to that
family member and stay there until they
go to court right they never go to court
okay look here your smart play tag with
these cases on many occasions how many
percentage of individuals who've been
ordered to port it show up with their
hearings go ahead and Rica you know
someone about fifty five percent about
55 percent of the brand net in these
cases they never showed up that is a
complete lie they do not show up for
their deportation hearings Brandon
there's a liar here we're talking to
former ruse why you on with us if you're
gonna call us a liar why are you want a
network that's filled with Liars that's
right Brandon I asked you a simple
question and you obfuscated and went to
another point which is cute but it
really doesn't work on this show I asked
you a question
how is it how how is it enforcing US law
to say if you cross the border illegally
you will most assuredly if unless you
are a known felon you will be released
after a short period of time to a
sponsor and you will be flown via
commercial airline with an HHS sponsor
escort to your location of choice and on
my question was how is that comporting
with the rule of law
now you may answer and then Brandon will
get a shot it's not happening
it's very rare exceptions that that
takes place so it's important that you
know the facts that you speak the facts
don't talk about exceptions talk about
the reality 45 cent drop in undocumented
migration in the last five years long
before Trump okay well drop we have
sixty six hundred and twenty-one percent
increase in southwest border family unit
apprehensions from April 2017 to
December 2017 we had a thousand one
hundred and twenty six family units
crossing in April December we had eight
thousand one hundred and twenty one
in one month one month 8121 families
crossing the border in anticipation
undoubtedly of an amnesty brand and I
did not give you enough time here but
let me what if Henrique might let you
speak for five seconds go ahead
Brandon Laura I can personally tell you
I get a shift patrolling the border
today I can personally tell you we let
go nearly all those those individuals
that cross under the Obama
administration now it's it's been much
better under the Trump administration
but you still have those Obama holdovers
that are forcing us to process the the
illegal aliens that we catch and and set
them up so that they can then turn
around and release them and that's got a
change and I am hopeful that it's going
to change because we know that President
Trump is tough on immigration he just
has to deal with those Obama holdovers
and want to do a sound bite from a
flight attendant who called in to my
radio show today
let's listen really quick there were
four of them they took up four seats in
first class young women and young
children they all have on brand new
clothes one bag of all brand-new
belongings no identification whatsoever
now we had to cut that short but she
went on to say they had a escort with
them and she didn't know where they
ended up ultimately but this happens
time and time again she's a long time
flight attendant she knew what she was
talking about Henrique really quickly
you can respond sure once you ask Chris
Harris he's a Border Patrol Union guy
ask him what he shot a migrant and
killed the migrant this is what's really
taking place along the border so you
take these exceptional cases and try to
make it sound like it's happening all
the time
these are rare exceptions that people
are forced to flee much of it because
the US interference in those countries
the US should be much more water denied
even in the top 20 countries when a
drink I mean you just don't want a
border at all I mean I do want a border
border it's more I want to do mainly I
don't want a border what's a human know
what I do I do order that Swiss cheese
what is that I don't know that's not
what I want I want humane intelligent
for you yeah yeah this is a cliche that
doesn't mean I want a humane border what
does that mean you know people should be
able to come in from you should be alive
the wine policies and age for other
meaning of demands that you